hey it's justine and that's also justine
in my animal crossing world so as you
guys know i'm a huge animal crossing fan
and this game has been so much fun to
play over the past several months
i also had started streaming this on
twitch
so during my time on twitch i would
stream in the morning and then as soon
as i was done streaming
you guys are probably familiar with mike
shinoda from linkin park
and he would start streaming around 10.
so as soon as i was done doing my live
stream
i would then go watch his live stream
where he would make a song
every single day so it's really cool to
see his songwriting process
every single day on twitch so since my
twitch stream would kind of go over and
watch him afterwards
we started making a little stage
on my animal crossing island which is
what you're seeing back here
so we just gotta slowly piece by piece
build this stage and then we're kind of
joking like what if mike shinoda came to
my island
and played a song you guys this is the
video
highlights of mike shinoda coming to my
island and playing a song and it's a
song that he wrote
it's an ijustine theme song short
version of story
when i first started streaming earlier
this year ijustine also started
streaming
she raided me i rated her then i found
out that she has
on her she's an animal crossing island
she
made a mike shinoda concert menu on her
island
which is both very exciting
and a tiny bit creepy
i can't even handle it right now so
here's how it all went down
oh hi i'm also at your oh my gosh you're
at my island
this is this is crazy they're like color
coordinated
wait i have that same shirt hold on a
second hold on i got to see if i have my
cat one
i do oh my gosh
there we go wait we have the same shoes
on almost
these are two gifts for you oh thank you
these are
these are just like the entryway gifts
there's more and a tambourine
emergency tambourine i mean i was
freaking emergency damage i was like
guys i've only got one so what made you
get
into the animal crossing when did i get
into it like what did this whole thing
everything was like coveted and
quarantined you joined at the same time
right
it was like i don't know march or april
or something i started streaming in the
morning like as soon as i woke up and
then you started streaming and i was
like oh my gosh i'll just send my people
over there after i'm done so it was
around the same time
okay let's look at this island oh my
gosh i have not like gotten a like
walked around this island i mean right
here
so the lily of the valley so you go
you've got two open
space is there are there more somewhere
else maybe
i don't think so because my island
stopped being five stars after i started
becoming a hoarder
i've got a little like collection of
mine i don't know what i'm gonna do with
them yet so i'm trying to figure out
where i should take you first
do you think they got in trouble for
making an apple tv well but it's an
actually apple
have you have you seen raymond do you
want to go see raymond i would love to
see raymond
this is a really i love all of the the
decorations the decor in the front i
don't think i've ever seen
raymond in person there he is dude hi
raymond can i talk to you
hi chat
raymond couldn't you have put your
litter box i mean in your office
i put that there the street
with the gutters oh yes you you're go
you went for it with this
i definitely logged over 700 hours in
like a few months so i'm not proud of it
it's that weird feeling i know most
people have the same thing
whose house is this this is my house
this is your house it's very exciting
um it's one of those like you don't know
whether to be
ashamed or proud of the hours you've
racked up
on certain things okay guys guys
my on my channel can we please
appreciate
the interior design going on here yeah
all right it's
all completely con conforms to the
palette
where do you see this next room talking
about conforming to a palette
do you decorate this way in real life oh
no
i like you walk into my house and you're
like what has happened here
is it just like boxes of like stuff
people have sent you to review
it's a lot of boxes yeah i mean i try
really hard but it's just
they just don't go away wait this is a
gym
sauna bathroom it's like very it's very
sweaty in here
we can leave it's fine uh this is uh oh
my god okay look
look look okay this is the studio okay
so like
cool what do i need what are the so what
are some tips for
first time product reviewers slash
youtube i mean just know that like you
can always edit so
feel free to mess up it's okay we can
redo it you know you want to do slow-mo
montages just to show off the products
you're doing great already look at you
i had a short-lived vlog when i was on
tour
that the fans named the lincoln log oh
my god
that's great and yeah it wasn't my i
didn't
i didn't choose the name and i shot and
edited it myself i'm just walking right
through this like it's not spectacular
like that is a lot of time i'm not gonna
this is nice like look at the color
we are nearing the stage how did it
become the stage
that it is welcome to the show i will
show you where you're going to be
performing
thank you thank you i'm so excited to be
here
you don't have to pay because uh we're
going to be paying you
to perform here is that a suitcase full
of gold
yeah that's where people give me the
money for the tickets they give
the tickets to my show on on justine's
island
are paid for in gold bars we only take
gold bars
and there's uh some tickets there too
when you walk down here this is kind of
the entryway
uh this is the parking lot oh wow
this is look at the stars look at the
little stars on the beach
you can pick those up if you want i had
a meteor shower last night we even have
i'm in the magazines custom in japanese
though do you catch that
no they're in japanese there are cameras
yeah we have to work
it's gonna be live stream of course pink
laptops on a on the
the gear rack here this is one of the
nicest stages
better than real life is my what i'm
trying to get at i was trying to make
sure it was laid out nicely so you could
get to all of the instruments
the skull the robot pink robot in the
background
oh yeah this is a like a hollow body
electric guitar over here i am obsessed
with those in real life right now
it is totally set up for like a whole
band
to play oh yeah you can't just be alone
like this is a whole
group effort can you jump on an
instrument and can we play a song
yeah i'm going to lead are you ready for
this we have a surprise for you
a surprise yeah we have a surprise
well no i should say we have a surprise
you know that i make a new thing from
scratch every day
you know we'll make up a theme or i'll
pull a theme out of uh basically out of
a hat and
yesterday's theme was ijustine and this
is what we made
oh my gosh
[Music]
oh
yes
[Music]
now
oh my goodness oh my gosh i'm gonna just
fall out of my chair
so you told me not to go to your stream
and let me tell you the only thing that
i wanted to do all week was go to your
stream but i did not
did not that's incredible the fans were
so
they were pumped i think the beginning
of the stream i came
into it knowing like exactly what i
wanted to make
when that happens sometimes the
beginning of the stream is me
a little bit in my head like going okay
we need to do this and we need to do
that
and this is how it's going to work
because i know where it's going to go
the earlier parts of the stream is like
watching a crazy person
it probably doesn't make a ton of sense
but then once we got halfway through the
stream he's like oh okay now
this is really coming into like a shape
and i know i understand
i tried to do everything really
digitally so the voice is actually
a vocaloid which is like the same as
like hatsune miku
and then the um there's a cameo by kk
slider in there
oh my gosh this is something and um
oh yeah and the lyrics were based on
like i was just trying to
kind of riffing off of the um the eye
yeah
you know i just seen like it was like um
riffing off of the pronoun thing
so that's the yeah and that's how it
came together it's incredible oh my gosh
i'm freaking out it's so good how long
did it take you to make it it was a
little over two hours
that's generally the the like time on
the stream like
sometimes they go over i think this one
was like maybe two and a half
what's going on here with the doggy this
is your dog that's my dog maddie yeah
that's his little dj separatist oh
that's
maddie's turntable okay yeah this is
like a side stage you know like he was
you know warming yeah well maddie would
be like warming up the crowd over here
here's your gifts i still think i'm
laughing at some of the things
some of the things that um i picked out
are really
funny and stereo oh fancy
a spider web
spider web was my favorite oh my gosh i
have so many gifts
this is great a poncho style sweater how
did you know it's what i always wanted
this was the big one that the fans
encouraged me to buy before
i got a gas mask oh my god these are so
many gifts
oh my god a computer yes oh my gosh this
is so exciting
a wasp head model these are all i just
can't even believe it a silver mic we're
gonna add another mic stand
this is uh this is the green room we
were trying to figure out what type of
cake you liked
i thought chocolate that one looks that
looks like an incredible cake
it does look really good i'm so sad that
it's not real like look at that that
looks so good like some tea
also we weren't sure if you like coffee
or tea so we put both
i am a co i am a coffee drinker usually
i i like tea but i i always drink coffee
oh is this like a sarcophagus
this knocks the villager that lives here
he's a murderer
okay so so i gave him are we are we
really gonna go like over
yeah are we going to his house like
right well do you want to go in yeah he
when you go out go to his house
he's got a full of like coffins i put a
freezer out there so we can put the body
some garbage bags
to put the parts in which character is
knox he's a chicken
oh my god knox you're so
scary he's right oh i shouldn't have
talked to him now he knows my name
he's got a little baseball jersey on
yeah this was his uh his murder village
oh the gas
is so that he can burn burn yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know
hide the evidence so i thought you said
yours channel was family friendly what
the heck well
we don't swear but we talk about murder
so i guess
yeah i guess it's gotta you know it's
gotta come around come out somehow
wait you've got a snowman is it spring
on your island now it
is i'm so sad but winter's amazing
you're gonna love it
it's so cool thank you so much thank you
so much for coming over this was amazing
and like i'm a big fan of your work for
forever so it's it's an honor to have
you come to our island so
i i it was awesome to see it you guys
have you and your
your crew have made an incredible and
welcoming
place it's amazing thank you so much
have a good rest of your day
thank you you too yeah thank you so much
for coming have a good flight
thanks bye bye thank you guys so much
for watching this video and
a huge thank you to mike for coming over
to my island and writing this incredible
song
like this is just it really is the
coolest thing ever you guys want to
check out mike's twitch channel it is
twitch.tv
official mike shinoda he also has a
youtube channel where he posts all of
his past streams
and of course he's on instagram and
twitter and i will put all of those
links in the description below so you
can check it out make sure you guys go
tell him hello and tell him that you
enjoyed the song tell him that you
enjoyed the stream and be sure to check
out his twitch streams where he makes a
song every day
it's pretty cool to watch i'll see you
guys in my next video don't forget to
subscribe to my channel for new videos
we do lots of cool tech stuff here
and i'll see you guys in the next video
[Music]
bye